dans le jardin du château une silhouette
blanche vaporeuse semble flâner entre
les fleurs c'est madame de maintenon la
dernière épouse du roi soleil cette
oeuvre a été créé par un artiste nantais
autodidacte cédric verdure il fabrique
des personnages à partir de grillage de
poulailler il est vraiment sur le pliage
en fait il s'est vraiment inspiré de
l'origami et ce grillage qui est
particulier qui est un grillage avec des
mailles qui sont suffisamment larges
pour être aérienne mais suffisamment
serré pour garder de la solidité et être
en même temps souple pour être manipulé
venu en résidence au château l'artiste
s'est aussi inspirée de la faune
présente pour créer sur place des
animaux comme ces signes ou c'est
bernaches un peu plus loin deux gentils
fantômes garde le château de maintenon
ou s'est lancé une nouvelle offre
culturelle cette année depuis cette
année on essaie de mettre en place une
exposition par trimestre donc on a des
expositions plus classique et puis là
pour l'été on s'était dit vraiment ils
essaient l'idée de d'envahir un peu le
parc sans pour autant gêner le visiteur
qui vient en déambulation uniquement
pour voir le château donc c'est présent
sans être présent en tout une trentaine
de figures sont disséminés discrètement
dans tout le parc et sur les dix sept
mille visiteurs de cet été beaucoup
apprécié l'idée j'aime
bien parce que c'est léger et ça
contraste un peu avec tout ce qu'il ya
autour la lourdeur du château et cette
fin de la décoration et style louis xiv
les plus chanceux ont pu admirer les
oeuvres se parer de couleurs certains
soirs le château et l'aqueduc laissant à
leur place à des sculptures de lumière